ED AND SANDRA.
>> Sandra: GRIFF JENKINS.
THANK YOU.
>> Ed: STAYING IN WASHINGTON
THE SENATE FAILING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH ITS NEARLY $2
TRIAL PHASE 3 BILL.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING BACK
AND ANOTHER CHANCE TO PUSH THE
BILL FORWARD.
BILL CASSIDY WAS SOUNDING OFF
ON THIS PROGRAM AND HE SAYS
IT’S UNNECESSARY POLITICAL
DRAMA.
>> A BILL WILL PASS.
I THINK WHAT’S REQUIRED NOW IS
FOR DEMOCRATS TO BE HONEST.
LET’S HOPE DEMOCRATS COME TO
THE TABLE IN GOOD FAITH AS
OPPOSED TO HIDING THEIR CARDS
AND RECOGNIZE THAT WHATEVER
SHORT TERM GAIN THEY’RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE IT IS NOT WORTH IT.
>> Ed: CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL IS
LIVE ON CAPITOL HILL WHERE THE
ACTION IS.
>> MUCH OF THE CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW IS BASICALLY TRYING
TO HAMMER OUT A DEAL WITH THE
EXPECTATION THERE COULD BE A
SERIES OF VOTES IN ABOUT TWO
HOURS.
THE DEBATE, DISCUSSION RIGHT
NOW IS BETWEEN TREASURY
SECRETARY STEVE MNUCHIN AND
SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER CHUCK
SCHUMER.
THEY MET SIX TIMES YESTERDAY.
MNUCHIN SAYS THE STIMULUS
PACKAGE IS $2 TRILLION AND
RESPONDED TO CRITICISM THAT
$500 BILLION OF IT IS A SMRUSH
FUND.
>> IT’S A MECHANISM THAT WE CAN
USE WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
RESERVE THAT WILL PROVIDE
ANOTHER $4 TRILLION OF
POTENTIAL LICK I  -- LIQUIDITY.
A MASSIVE LIQUIDITY PROGRAM IS
THE PRESIDENT IS DETERMINED
WE’LL SUPPORT HARD-WORKING
AMERICANS.
>> MITCH MCCONNELL AND ALLIES
ARE ACCUSING SCHUMER AND OTHER
DEMOCRATS OF SEEKING TO INCLUDE
AN IDEOLOGICAL WISH LIST THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
CORONAVIRUS.
MCCONNELL VENTED HIS
FRUSTRATION.
>> OUR NATION CANNOT AFFORD THE
GAME OF CHICKEN.
WE CAN’T AFFORD THE CYNICAL,
PARTISANSHIP AND UNCONSCIONABLE
STATEMENT TO VIEW THIS AS A
PARTISAN OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS, MR. PRESIDENT, A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, NOT A
PARTISAN OPPORTUNITY.
>> ADDING TO THE STRESS FOR
MCCONNELL, FIVE OF HIS MEMBERS
ARE OUT OF ACTION NOW.
SENATOR RAND PAUL TESTED
POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS AND
SENATORS MIKE LEE, MITT ROM
NAOE, RICK SCOTT AND CORY
GARDNER ARE IN SELF-QUARANTINE.
SO FAR NO SIGN DEMOCRATS ARE
BUDGING.
>> OUR CAUCUS IS UNITED IN
TRYING TO DELIVER A BILL THAT
ADDRESSES THIS HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS QUICKLY.
AND WE’RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
IN A BIPARTISAN WAY TO GET IT
DONE.
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE VOTING
FOR A BILL.
>> THERE IS SOME HEALTH
PRESSURE AND FINANCIAL MARKET
PRESSURE AS WE ALL DO A LITTLE
SOCIAL DISTANCING HERE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> Ed: YOU WERE JUST REPORTING
A MOMENT AGO THAT CHUCK SCHUMER
MET WITH THE TREASURY SECRETARY
SIX TIMES YESTERDAY.
COUNTLESS PHONE CALLS BETWEEN
THE TREASURY SECRETARY AND
VARIOUS DEMOCRATS OVER THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR DAYS I’M SURE.
HOW CAN DEMOCRATS NOW CLAIM
THAT THEY WERE LEFT OUT OF THE
PROCESS WHEN IT HAS BEEN ON
RECORD AND THEY WERE ON TAPE
OVER THE WEEKEND SAYING THEY
WERE WORKING TOGETHER?
>> A LOT OF FRUSTRATION IS THAT
THE SENATORS FELT LIKE THEY
WERE GETTING VERY, VERY CLOSE
TO A DEAL AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI CAME IN
FROM CALIFORNIA AFTER BEING OUT
OF THE MIX FOR A WEEK OR SO AND
SO THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
FRUSTRATION FEELING LIKE THERE
WAS SOME TRUST BUILDING BETWEEN
BOTH PARTIES AND ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION TRYING TO GET
CLOSE TO FINALIZING A DEAL.
YOU MAY RECALL THE PREVIOUS
DEAL YOU HAD SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL SAYING
LET SPEAKER PELOSI AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAMMER OUT A
DEAL.
WHEN THEY DO WE’LL PASS IT.
PELOSI GOT BACK AND CAME BACK
AND THROWING IN THINGS NOW AT
THE 11th HOUR THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH CORONAVIRUS.